[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
today i'm going to be joined by sean
carroll from caltech and santa fe
institute
who's a theoretical physicist who's been
really studying
the nature of time itself and the human
experience of time and really how we fit
in it and here at long now we've been
doing talks
that kind of relate to time in many ways
but this is the first time that we're
doing it
on time itself i'm very excited to have
sean here
welcome sean carroll thanks very much
sandra it's a great pleasure to be
talking about time the nature of time
what it means for all of us
at the long now foundation obviously
folks at long now have been thinking
very carefully about time
about the human aspects of time about
how to measure it how to
think about it and that's my jam that's
what i'm very very
interested in doing you know time is
just so important
to who we are as human beings right we
feel like
time is passing around us or we're
flowing through time
the metaphors they go back and forth i'm
not sure whether we're moving through
time or time is moving around
us but either way time is just crucial
to what it means to be a person we plan
for the future we remember the past
some of us are so fascinated by the
nature of time that we become
professional physicists
and we learn about what time means from
the physicist's point of view
and we learn a lot like physicists
understand a
great deal about the nature of time but
there's something interesting
maybe a little scary that happens when
you learn about time from the
perspective of physicists you learn
equations they tell you how physical
systems evolve
but this idea that time passes
or the time flows or that somehow we
move through time
that central most obvious idea about
time in our everyday lives
disappears it's nowhere to be found
in the fundamental laws of physics but
it's clearly there in our everyday lives
and we think
that we're made of things that follow
the fundamental laws of physics so
what is going on that's what i want to
talk about with you
today how to reconcile how physicists
think about time with how we experience
it in our everyday lives
and what that reconciliation teaches us
for what time means and what it means to
be a person
so let me start by explaining what i
mean when i say that this
passage of time notion disappears when
you learn about time from the physicist
point of view
what does a physicist do what's a
typical physicist kind of problem
to contemplate okay well think about the
planets
in the solar system moving around the
sun this is the kind of thing that
physicists are really good at
paradigmatic kepler galileo newton those
people
you're given the state of some physical
system by which
in this case we mean the positions of
all the planets where they're located in
space
and how they're moving right the
velocity at just one moment of time you
don't need to be given the history of
the planets
at one moment of time you're given where
they are
and how they're moving right now and
then you have a recipe you have the laws
of physics you have newton's laws of
motion
and newton's law of gravitation and from
those
you can predict the future from the
present state of the system you can tell
where it's going to be next you can
predict eclipses in the future
you can say where the planets are going
to be you can make an almanac okay
but there's something extra that is very
very important you can also
predict the past or retrodict if you
prefer
given the current state of the system
the laws of physics tell you
exactly what was going on in the entire
past history of the system
and real astronomers actually do this
they extrapolate the current state of
the solar system millions or billions of
years
into the past and the future so
buried underneath that little discussion
is an idea that we call
conservation of information all of the
information you need
about the system right now its positions
its velocities and so forth
suffices to predict the entire future
and past of the system if i told you
exactly the state of the system a
million
years ago you could predict what it
would be doing
right now this is the disappearance of
this idea that time is flowing
time to a physicist ever since isaac
newton
it becomes kind of a label there's this
moment there's the past moment there's
the future moment
there's nothing special about what we
call now or the present moment
the laws of physics describe every
moment of time
as being on an equal footing and the
information contained in every moment of
time
persists into the past and the future
that's very different from what we're
used to in our everyday lives just as
one simple example
imagine you come across there's a glass
of water on the table it's a
slightly cool glass of water okay and
you ask yourself well
what was the state of that glass of
water a few minutes ago
maybe it was just a cool glass of water
just sitting there but maybe
it was a glass of room-temperature water
with some ice cubes in it and maybe
those ice cubes
melted and cooled off the water the
point is
just given the macroscopic observable
information about the world
you can't say where it came from
unlike the perfect information we have
for the solar system in the real world
where we see the glass of water and we
can see a little bit about it right it's
temperature whether there's ice in it or
not
but we're not looking at every atom or
molecule of water
then suddenly information is no longer
conserved
there's information that used to be
there in the system did it have an ice
cube in it or not
and that's disappeared over time we have
an
irreversible process so what we're
seeing in the macroscopic world
is what scientists and philosophers call
the arrow of time
the difference between the past and the
future in particular
the asymmetry that we have when we think
about
now versus the past versus the future
and that asymmetry that arrow of time is
not there in the fundamental laws of
physics we have to dig in
a little bit to understand where it
comes from so let me just explain
how that asymmetry between past and
future shows up
in our everyday lives one aspect is that
there is an asymmetry of knowledge
okay in a very real sense you can
predict the future
but you're never really sure what's
going to happen right you know sometimes
our predictions come out wrong
whereas when it comes to the past we can
have records
we can have memories there are things
that exist
in the universe right now which we're
very very confident
tell us something specific about an
event that happened in the past whether
it's a photograph
or a book or a fossil a bone underneath
the earth
these are artifacts right now that
represent something definite about the
past
we don't have photographs or artifacts
that tell us about the future in the
same way
but there's another asymmetry not just
knowledge between past and future
there's an asymmetry of
influence between the past and future we
have in our minds the idea that the past
is settled
right it happened there's nothing you
can do about it whereas
toward the future we can make choices
we can do things now that affect
the future if you lift your left hand
versus lifting your right hand
that might have an impact on the future
but nobody thinks
that by doing something right now you
can influence
the past where did these asymmetries
come from
why is it that we can know more about
the past but we can influence the future
in some way
again it's nowhere in newton's laws of
motion
okay nor in any update of newton's laws
of motion general relativity
electromagnetism
schrodinger's equation in quantum
mechanics all of these attempts
at finding a fundamental laws of physics
have the feature
that they treat the past present and
future equally
now i'm not going to hold you in
suspense too much i actually know the
answer to this question
why is the past present and future so
different to us
the answer is something called entropy
and the second law of thermodynamics i'm
sure you've heard about this
before entropy is basically roughly not
exactly but close enough
the disorderliness of a system the
randomness the disorganization
and there is a law of nature that is
true in our macroscopic everyday world
that says that entropy increases over
time so a typical example might be an
egg
you can have an unbroken egg it's easy
enough to break the egg
to scramble the egg and in that process
from unbroken to broken to scrambled
the entropy of the egg increases you're
mixing things up you're making them more
random and that would just happen very
easily and naturally in the world
whereas
if you saw a movie of scrambled eggs
reforming into an unbroken egg
you would know right away someone was
playing the movie
backwards in time there's a
directionality to the evolution of these
systems
so the first law of thermodynamics just
says energy is constant that's good
the second law says that entropy
increases over time
in a closed isolated system or in the
universe as a whole
you can clean up your room don't get me
wrong you can lower the entropy in a
localized system by
influencing it from the outside world
but overall
in the universe as a whole entropy
increases over time
so unlike newton's laws or other
attempts at fundamental laws of physics
the second law of thermodynamics does
tell the difference between the past
present and future it says that entropy
will be higher in the future
it was lower in the past good that's
nice that's an explanation of something
but
we want to do better why is it the case
why does entropy go up over time so this
was
roughly speaking solved in the 1870s by
ludwig boltzmann an austrian physicist
and some of his friends
what they did was they said entropy is
not just a rough idea
it's a highly precise quantitative
concept that we can attach equations to
that's what physicists like to do with
their lives attach equations to things
you thought you understood
so entropy in boltzmann formulation is
just look
when you look at a system a macroscopic
thing a glass of water with an ice cube
in it or
cream and coffee or an egg you
don't see every little bit of that
system you don't see the molecules you
don't see the atoms of which it is made
so let's take cream and coffee as a
classic example okay
if the cream and coffee are separate
from each other
there's a number of ways you could
imagine changing the positions
of the individual molecules in the cream
or molecules in the coffee
so that macroscopically you wouldn't be
able to tell the difference
but if you started mixing them together
if you started taking the cream and
mixing into the coffee you would be able
to tell the difference so there's a
small number of rearrangements you could
imagine
whereas if it's all mixed up right if
all the cream and all the coffee are
mixed together
then there are a large number of ways
you can rearrange the atoms and
molecules
to make it look exactly the same so
boltzmann says
that's what entropy is entropy is a way
of
counting how many ways there are to
rearrange the fundamental constituents
of a system
so that it macroscopically looks the
same
to us from that point of view it's not
at all surprising that entropy
goes up as a function of time it's
simply because
there are more ways to be high entropy
than to be low entropy
if you have a medium entropy system and
just let it go
let it do its thing let it evolve into
the universe
it will naturally increase in entropy
since there are so many more
configurations that look that way
that part is easy the hard part is
if you have a medium entropy system why
was it lower entropy in the past
if it started lower entropy you can
explain why but you seem to need a new
principle to explain that and indeed
that is exactly
true think of the arrow of time this way
there's no arrow of space right if you
were an astronaut floating out there in
space there'd be no
difference between up down left right
forward backward but you know if you're
here on earth there's an arrow of space
you can tell the difference between
up and down nobody thinks that arrow of
space
is deeply ingrained in the fundamental
nature of reality it's just because
you're
in the vicinity of an influential object
the earth
the same story is true for the arrow of
time the arrow of time according to
modern physics is not
built into the fundamental nature of
reality we experience it because we live
in the aftermath of an influential event
the big bang 14 billion years ago
for reasons that cosmologists do not
understand
the big bang was very low entropy the
early universe
was very orderly compared to what it
could have been now why is that true
good question very active research
question at the frontiers of modern
cosmology but for our purposes today
we don't know why but it's true the big
bang had a low entropy and once you say
that
it's clear that entropy is going to go
up it's been going up for the last 14
billion years it's going to continue to
go up
billions and billions of years into the
future
so good we think we know what entropy is
the number of ways you can rearrange a
system
we think it makes sense that entropy
increases over time
what we're left to do is understand what
this has to do
with our experience of time in the
everyday world
how does that help explain this
asymmetry we have about the past versus
the future
this feeling that we have that we're
flowing through time
well let's just take one example here's
my favorite example of an asymmetry
this is an asymmetry of prediction
versus records you're walking down the
street
you look down the sidewalk you see a
broken egg can we ask ourselves because
we're in a philosophical mood
what is the future of that egg likely to
hold
you don't know right there's many
different possible things that could
happen to the egg it could just sit
there
it could be cleaned up by somebody there
could be a rainstorm washing it away
there's many possible futures open but
if you ask yourself
what is the past of that egg probably
involve
with very high confidence you will
believe that there used to be an
unbroken egg and it got dropped and it
broke
so right away just seeing this thing in
the world right now this artifact
broken egg on the sidewalk you infer a
difference
between the past history of that egg and
the future history of that egg why
well it's not because of the fundamental
laws of physics
given the configuration today egg on the
ground
messy etc there are many many
arrangements
of the individual molecules that could
account for that
and accordingly there are many many
possible futures as we said many things
could happen
to the egg if all you knew
were the fundamental laws of physics
there is a precisely equal number
of past things that the egg could have
gone through
the conservation of information
convinces us that the number of past
possible histories of that egg is
exactly equal
to the number of future possible
histories of that egg
but there is one big difference that we
know the universe started with a big
bang
and that big bang had a very low entropy
this is what
philosophers call the past hypothesis of
low entropy
in the universe so we know two things we
know the current state of the egg
and we know the initial condition that
we started with very low entropy
we that's where the imbalance comes from
that's where we know a little bit
something more about the past than about
the future and we can use that
information
to say given the existence of a broken
egg on the sidewalk
today and the existence of a very very
low entropy big bang
we can infer that there used to be an
unbroken egg
as you go through your life as you are
remembering things and predicting things
about the future you are
constantly relying on the fact that the
entropy of the universe was very
low near the big bang you might not have
known that you are relying on that fact
but it's crucially important
to how we live our lives that's the good
news we can say something
about where this asymmetry comes from
this asymmetry of
both knowledge and influence toward the
past and the future
but it raises kind of another worry that
we didn't have before
which is the following you know if all
that happens over the history of the
universe
is that disorder increases how did i get
here
i think of myself as relatively orderly
right the organs of my body the neurons
in my brain they're organized in kind of
a precise way
how could you tell me that something as
exquisitely organized as a living being
just came to exist out of increasing
entropy over time and of course you know
because i'm asking you this question
that i know what the answer is to this
at least i know a little bit this is
another active research area
but let's go back to our favorite
example of the cream mixing into coffee
it begins in a very low entropy state
the cream and the coffee mix together it
ends up in a high entropy state
but that early low entropy state is very
simple right all the creams on the top
all the coffee's on the bottom
that final high entropy state is also
very simple everything's mixed together
it's
in between it's that intermediate state
on the journey from low entropy to high
entropy where
things look complicated where the cream
and the coffee are mixing together
in unpredictable ways forming little
swirls little fractal patterns that
would require
a lot of information to specify so
that's the secret and we have a lot to
learn still to go about this but
basically
complexity naturally arises
on the journey from low entropy to high
entropy
this is a we think a fundamental feature
of how the universe
works that there's something about the
journey from
a simple beginning with very very low
entropy
to a simple ending with very very high
entropy
that can give rise to complexity so
entropy just goes up
but complexity first goes up and then
goes down
it's a temporary phenomenon which might
make you
pleased to understand what's going on
maybe a little worried
about the ephemeral nature of things
like that in the universe and indeed
this is not just a story about cream and
coffee
this is a story we can tell about the
universe as a whole
the big bang was about 14 billion years
ago and right after the big bang the
universe was very low entropy
also very simple it was hot dense smooth
rapidly expanding that's all you need to
know over time what happens is the
universe expands
and cools and structures begin to form
gravity pulls things together and we can
see this we can take an image
of the background radiation from the big
bang from a few hundred thousand years
after the beginning
you can see the first faint traces of
structures forming
today 14 billion years later our
universe is rich with structures
there are planets stars galaxies people
clusters
voids it's a very lumpy interesting
exciting kind of universe
but that's temporary it's not going to
last forever
stars use up their fuel they burn out
they go dark
stars fall into black holes even black
holes don't last forever in the 1970s
stephen hawking taught us
black holes radiate out into the
universe and eventually evaporate away
completely we think roughly speaking
that
10 to the 100 years from now which is a
long time even by long now standards
all the black holes in the universe will
have evaporated away into almost
nothing we think the universe is
expanding and it's going to keep
expanding forever
we don't know that for sure remember
predicting the future is hard
but that's the best current theory we
have so the very far
future of the universe is very high
entropy
but once again very very simple we
for what it's worth live in the exciting
part
of the history of the universe and we
are part of that excitement
and maybe this is a story you're willing
to believe on general grounds complexity
comes and goes etc but
the leap from there to the specific
complexity of a living organism might be
a little bit hard
to swallow right you in fact you're
taught
sometimes i wish you weren't but it's
true you're taught that living organisms
are somehow
fighting against entropy they're
resisting entropy right
i think the opposite of that is true my
friend michael russell who's one of the
world's leading researchers
in the beginning of life the origin of
life here on earth once told me
the purpose of life is to hydrogenate
carbon dioxide
now that might not be the purpose of
your life but what he meant was
why did life start in the first place in
his theory and no one agrees
okay there's very large number of
different theories that are competing
right now but he has one of the
interesting ones
russell says there was an overabundance
of carbon dioxide
in the early earth and that was a low
entropy way
for those carbon atoms to be it would be
much higher entropy
for those carbon atoms to get rid of
their oxygen and take on hydrogen
convert into methane okay hydrogenate
the carbon dioxide
the problem was there's no simple way to
get
from there to here from carbon dioxide
to methane no simple reaction makes that
happen
what does make it happen is a complex
network of reactions
under exactly the right circumstances so
russell used this idea to make a
prediction
that underneath the oceans there should
be warm
hydrothermal vents of a very very
specific chemistry
and after he made that prediction it was
shown to be
true we found things like the lost city
formation
at the bottom of the atlantic ocean a
warm hydrothermal vent
which have exactly this complex chemical
structure
and russell's idea is that this network
of chemical reactions can get caught up
in a vessel a cell membrane
break away and form a precursor to life
here on earth now again we don't know
it's one theory but the point i'm trying
to make is
the existence of life is not something
that is a struggle against
the growth of entropy it is something
that is made possible
by the growth of entropy and once you
have that
once you have these little complex
networks that are using up the entropy
around them
they can last for a long time and i want
to emphasize this because this goes into
not just the origin of life but what you
are doing right now the nature of us
as bodies and beings here in the world
roughly speaking you can think about
things that persist okay configurations
of matter that last for a long time
there's two ways to be a persistent
object here
in the world one way is to be made of
individual pieces individual atoms and
molecules
that are themselves more or less
stationary we might call this
microstasis the chair underneath you
right now
is made of a whole series of molecules
that are held together in a rigid
pattern
they're not doing anything they're not
going anywhere there's a solidity to it
which maintains over time
but there's another paradigm which we
might call homeostasis
where you have patterns that persist
over time even if the individual
pieces that make up those patterns are
moving
that sounds a lot more like life to me
right it's not
just life think about the great red spot
on jupiter this is a storm
okay this is a storm of swirling gases
in the atmosphere of jupiter that has
persisted for hundreds of years
it's not that there's one lump there
that is absolutely stationary
the pattern maintains over time
that's what you are that's what i am we
are patterns that get
maintained over time because there's a
lot of activity beneath the surface
you can try your best to be completely
stationary
right you can still your breathing lower
your heart rate enter a meditative state
but whether you notice it or not at the
cellular level there's a lot of action
going on a lot of atp molecules are
being created
and used atps are little batteries that
fuel your system
you can stay as still as you want but if
you plop your body
out there in the desert away from fuel
away from water and food and so forth
you will not
last for very long what we really do
is we maintain the persistence of the
patterns we call our body
by taking in fuel from the outside and
using that for maintenance for
homeostasis
why is that possible because entropy is
increasing all of those processes that
keep
us maintained require an increase in
entropy of the universe here on earth
mostly that comes from the sun right we
think to ourselves what does the sun do
for us as
in terms of life here on earth the sun
gives us energy
you might be tempted to say and that's
true but it's not the whole story
the earth radiates into space just
as much energy as it gets from the sun
the total amount of energy here on earth
is not really changing
that much the difference is for every
one
photon of light we get from the sun the
earth radiates
20 photons into outer space we get
visible light from the sun we radiate
infrared light out into space
so 20 photons of infrared with one
twentieth of the energy each
is what we do to the energy we get from
the sun
so in other words the sun gives us
energy
in a low entropy form one photon
we increase its entropy we do
photosynthesis we eat our food we think
we listen to talks we make great
speeches that we
radiate out into the universe the same
energy we got
but with a much higher entropy that's
what enables
all of the marvelous activity that
brings us to life
here on earth and that process is to
come back to where we started what
explains the idea
that we feel that time is passing around
us
that imbalance between past present and
future caused by the fact that
entropy is increasing so if you think
about it you think about yourself
right now at the present moment you are
in some configuration right your body is
doing
some particular thing and a day ago or a
second ago it was also
in some particular configuration a
second from now or a day from now it
will be in some particular configuration
but you don't know right you don't have
exact knowledge you have
vague knowledge of what your body's
doing right now you don't even have
perfect knowledge of that
you kind of have a memory of where it
was and you can predict where it will be
and let's think about that process not
the scale of days or years but of
seconds or
milliseconds okay the point is we are
constantly carrying with us in our minds
an image of our body and not just an
image of our body right now we have a
pretty good idea what our bodies are
doing right now even though it's
imperfect right we don't have perfect
knowledge of anything
we also carry around where our body was
we carry the memory of what we were
doing just a tiny fraction of a second
ago
and we project into the future our our
brains are constantly doing this
they're making predictions about where
we will be
where our bodily configuration will be a
fraction of the second in the future
and they're constantly comparing its
prediction
as we made it to what we're perceiving
as where we are right now
and to what we think we were doing in
the past
it is that constant process of
comparison
past present and future on millisecond
time scales
that's what gives us the feeling that
time is passing
the feeling that we are moving through
time because there's an imbalance
we know a little bit more about the past
we make predictions about the future
we constantly take in more data more
information and we
update and every single update gives us
the impression
that we are moving through time that's
not just us
of course that's not just human beings
every animal species does something like
this
but we human beings do a little bit more
than the average animal species
we think about the future in different
ways okay
every animal species needs to react to
its present circumstance but you know
that human beings can react to a lot
more than a fraction of a second right
we can
think about the future we can
contemplate it we can plan
we can imagine different possible
futures
that is a very precious gift that took a
long time for evolution
to give us malcolm mciver who is a
neuroscientist at northwestern
university has a theory about this
his theory is that it comes back down to
the first fish
that climbed onto land okay you may have
heard of the fossil tiktaalik
which is probably one of the first fish
that climbed onto land
and mackyver's idea is that when you're
a fish you can't see that far in front
of you
even if you're in very clear water the
attenuation length of light in water is
only a few meters you see things in
front of you but not very far away
so all of the evolutionary pressure when
you live in the water
is to see something and react to it
right away
is it friend is it faux is it food
whereas when you climb onto land
now you can see forever roughly speaking
right on a clear day there's no optical
to how far you can see
you can see things so far away it will
take you time
to interact with them in some way and
therefore
a new possibility opens up for evolution
to choose to develop in your brain which
is
the possibility to see something and
rather than just instantly react to it
think about the possible things you
could do
hypothesize different scenarios imagine
them
this idea is the birth of imagination
and in fact you can see how evolution
did this evolution uses
things over and over again and
neuroscientists have shown
that the part of your brain that lights
up when you're imagining a scene in the
future
is the same part of your brain that
lights up when you're remembering a
scene
from the past it's this ability
to imagine different future hypothetical
scenarios
that really has reached its apotheosis
in human beings we are better than this
at this than any other species of
animals and this is what really
makes us particularly human you could
talk about this in many different ways
here's an example
la sagrada familia this is a cathedral
in barcelona and it was started
constructed
back in 1883 under the guidance of
antoni gowdy he took over from other
people who started it but gowdy designed
what he thought the cathedral should
look like it's an absolute masterwork
very very complicated a million
different moving parts and different
kinds of
styles and so forth and gowdy passed
away
in 1926 and the cathedral was nowhere
near finished when he passed away and he
knew
perfectly well that it would not be
finished when he passed away
but he still wanted to do it even though
he knew it wouldn't be finished when he
died
what is going on what's going on is
gowdy could use his brain
to imagine what it would be like in that
future time when the cathedral was done
and it made him happy then the point is
not that gowdy thought that he would be
a ghostly
uh persistence over time that would be
looking down on the cathedral and
admiring it
he gained pleasure right at that moment
from the prospect of the future
and that's something that we humans have
the ability to do
the conditions of ourselves right now
depend out on our visions of the past
and the future as well as our conditions
here
in the present so it all goes back
to the cream mixing into the coffee okay
entropy
increasing over time that's the story of
the passage of time in the universe but
it's that middle phase
where the cream is mixing into the
coffee where those little swirls
develop those swirls are us
that's what you and i are we are
temporary little bits
of complex structure in the universe
that are
part of the overall increase of entropy
over time that means we are ephemeral
we're not going to last forever that's
the bad news
okay we're not going to last for 10 to
the 10 to the 10 years we have a
lifespan we have an expiration date
but it also means we are interesting we
are
the interesting part of the universe
part of this complexity
is our ability to think about and model
ourselves and the rest of the universe
to do what psychologists call
mental time travel to imagine ourselves
not just in different places but at
different times it's that ability that
imagination
that flow through time that makes us
what we are
as human beings
thank you so much sean that was
fantastic i i especially
love it when we have somebody speaking
that makes the ten thousand year
reference of
long now seem like a blink of an eye so
i'd love to welcome you for our q a
hi xander thanks very much for having me
here thank you for joining us from la
i'm here at the interval in san
francisco um
soon to be open finally to uh to people
walking and i'm looking forward to it
uh later this month um but i think
what i'd love to kind of talk about a
little bit is this
um is this notion of you know
you mentioned the universe as we know it
is um
is the you know the milk as it starts to
swirl in the coffee that we're we're at
this interesting part
of the universe and i'm just wondering
where
a where do we think we are in that
process did the milk just hit the coffee
um is are we almost to a static
uh you know homogeneic uh universe
um and and our is there some notion that
we kind of try and make ourselves feel
better about being in the most
interesting
time in the world yeah you know i think
we shouldn't get too greedy
here um there's a lot we don't
understand about this whole process and
what's really really important is that
there are
things going on on very different time
scales right the
evolution of the universe as a whole is
measured in billions or tens of billions
of years
human beings consider ourselves lucky if
we live for 100 years
so we don't know whether or not
complexity
is on the upswing in the universe as a
whole or on the downswing there's
certain things
that we can quantify you know mo like 95
of the stars that will ever exist
in the universe already have been formed
the universe is more or less done making
stars
but it takes time after you make a star
and make some planets to make a
biosphere and things like that you know
life
came onto the surface of the earth
relatively quickly
once the earth was formed but it took a
while for that life to become
eukaryotic and multicellular and so
forth so
i honestly don't know i don't even know
if that's a very answerable question but
i think we should enjoy the complexity
we have
try to increase it if we can but not
fret too much about whether or not we're
at the absolute maximum
nice and i think you started you started
to answer this question but i
uh maybe if we put it back in terms of
the egg it will
make more sense to me at least which is
that so that
there's an egg that gets cracked and
goes into higher entropy state but
there's also
the part of the act that we didn't talk
about which is the formation of the egg
and the chicken
and i think you talked about this as you
know as humans are formed into life
there's
and is that a is that a process that is
going towards higher entropy or lower
entropy
when the creation of something like the
egg before it gets cracked
you know if you include a large enough
system
the only processes that we have are ones
going to higher entropy there's no
processes that go to lower entropy
you can have an entropy decrease like i
said in the talk you can uh
clean your room that's okay that's the
localized champagne
yeah you can put it in the refrigerator
it will cool off its entropy will go
down that's all allowed
but it's only because it's increasing
the entropy somewhere else
the reason why you can't cool your
living room
by putting a refrigerator in there and
opening the front door
is because there's more heat coming out
of the back than there is cool
going out the front so overall if you
include enough stuff
entropy always goes up and that's why i
don't like to think about
life or other complicated things as
fighting against
the increase of entropy because that's a
losing battle we're not going to win
that one
what we can do is take advantage of the
evolution
that is caused by entropy increasing and
make that into something interesting and
important and meaningful
well that that example the refrigerator
is really helpful it's like why you
can't put a fan on a sailboat and
get anywhere that's right right so that
that that actually makes a lot of sense
so
uh and that you can do things in a
localized system but you're you're
basically robbing that
from somewhere else in a larger system
um
yeah when we started uh building this
ten thousand year clock project
one of the first uh material scientists
that i spoke to
um gave me the best picture in my head
of how we should think about
uh materials that are gonna last over
ten thousand years he said
everything is burning just at different
rates and that fundamentally like
everything is just oxidizing
um and you can choose kind of which
which materials that you want to use and
how fast they you want them to oxidize
but it was it was kind of ringing to me
as you as as you spoke is
uh that's our that's our entropic
process that we get to fight
when building something like a cloud
well and they weren't probably even
worrying about the fact that eventually
we'll fall into a black hole and be
radiated away
into intergalactic space but that's a
better ten billion
yeah i mean everything is burning
everything is running down the most
solid thing in the world
is not 100 static that's uh that's
physics for you and the
the ultimate state we think of the
universe is going to be nothing but
empty space
if you're not empty space you're not
done evolving yet
and so i mean i think you started a
little bit with this but what do you
what do you find is generally the kind
of
the largest misconception that people
have about time i mean you talked about
this arrow of time
versus this um this notion of entropy
and non-entropy is that
is that really what where people seem to
kind of have a misconception a common
sense of time
well that thing that i talked about
where once you start studying
time from the physics point of view a
new mystery arises
why is there a direction why is the past
any different from the future why is
there an arrow of time
many many people including a lot of
professionals who should know better
really have a difficult time intuiting
the fact
that if you're trying to explain why
that's true
explain why the past is different from
the future you cannot do it by
using assumptions that are themselves
asymmetric with respect to the past and
the future that's just cheating
that's explaining something in terms of
just another assumption that is just as
bad
uh it's very very difficult to put
ourselves
in the mindset of imagining that there
isn't an
intrinsic arrow of time to the nature of
stuff because
everything around us has such a manifest
unavoidable arrow of time
it's hard for us to get around it so
thinking in that
sense is is a real trick when it comes
to trying to think of how to explain the
universe as a whole
it's another effect of that localizing
effect where
on a local level time does feel like
very much it's an arrow
well as i said in the talk you know i
referred to the fact that we can explain
the arrow of time in our observable
universe by
assuming that the early universe near
the big bang was very very low entropy
we don't know why that's an open
question that people argue about
and there are plenty of papers in the
physics literature
that say oh i can explain this let me
assume the following very simple initial
condition for the universe near the big
bang and it's simple therefore it's
probably right
but they don't assume the same condition
for the final part of the universe for
the end of the universe
they put it on one side and not the
other and then they pet themselves on
the back for uh you know
showing that there's something
asymmetric about it it's just really
difficult the flow of time is so
embedded in who we are
that it's it's hard to imagine not
assuming it from the very start and how
is it that we know
um that the moment of the big bang was
so much lower entropy than now what's
what's our what's our evidence of this
well it's sort of a two-part little
dance that we have to go through that's
a very interesting uh difficult question
one is we can just look at it right we
have
data we have the images of the cosmic
microwave background the leftover
radiation from the big bang
so we know what the conditions or we
think we know what the conditions were
like near the big bang okay and we can
calculate their entropy we have formulas
for doing this and
the reason why well sorry that was a bit
of an exaggeration
we have formulas that work in certain
circumstances we don't have the once and
for all
formula for the entropy of the universe
as a whole but what we can do is to say
what's the entropy of a black hole okay
a single black hole you know our galaxy
the milky way galaxy has a super massive
black hole in the middle that is
millions of times the mass of the sun
you can calculate the entropy of that
stephen hawking told us how to do that
the entropy of that one black hole in
the middle of our galaxy
is bigger than the entropy of the whole
universe
near the big bang so we know that
however you want to
talk about it the entropy of the
universe near the big bang was
much lower than it was today it would
have been higher if there had been black
holes around but there weren't
and that when you say a black hole has
more entropy than it than another one
are you saying that it's
it's it's more the milk has swirled more
into that coffee like you're seeing a
more homo homeostatic kind of
version of it you know i can't tell you
the answer for that one that's above my
one of right this is one of the reasons
why this whole subject is so fascinating
you know in the 1970s
stephen hawking and some friends of his
noticed that there was an analogy
between the behavior of black holes and
the laws of thermodynamics
and they just said oh look that's a fun
analogy and then jacob beckenstein who's
a graduate student at the time said you
know what i don't think it's an analogy
i think it's actually an equivalence
black holes really are thermodynamic
systems with entropy and so forth
and hawking got annoyed by this he said
that's nonsense if black holes had an
entropy they would have to radiate they
would have a temperature they would give
off radiation and everyone knows that
black holes don't radiate
so he sat down to prove it and he ended
up proving they do radiate he invented
hawking radiation which is one of the
greatest discoveries of the
second half of the 20th century in
physics but
we still don't know what that entropy
represents in a very real sense so we
have from hawking and beckenstein
are formulas that we can plug in we can
tell you very accurately how much
entropy
is in a black hole just as we can tell
you the entropy of a cup of coffee
but for the cup of coffee we can say oh
because there's molecules
there's cream molecules and there's
coffee molecules
and if you say well what is it that are
the
equivalents of the molecules in the case
of the black hole
we just don't know right now interesting
and i wonder if you know part of the
issue is that we don't have good
visualization tools for
you know that we keep showing time on a
timeline um for instance but
have you come up are there good
visualization tools that would kind of
break this paradigm better
or show it better for people you know
it's a good question
uh i don't have any good uh answers as
to what a good visualization tool would
be
what i find very interesting is that
there is no universality in how people
visualize
time so if you become a professional
physicist
and you specialize in relativity or
cosmology
right space-time and the expansion of
the universe all that thing
and you want to draw a picture of the
universe what we call a space-time
diagram
for you time runs upward from the bottom
to the top
in every space-time diagram ever written
if you're a particle physicist
and you have two particles bumping into
each other and scattering off and you
want to draw a picture of that a fineman
diagram
to you time runs from left to right if
you're a computer scientist
talking about how algorithms go to you
time runs from top to bottom
so there are different ways that we
represent
time in space and now analogically
and uh there's a whole another you know
hour-long talk to be given about how
that gets represented in language
different spatial metaphors different
temporal metaphors and so whatever our
metaphors are it's hard for us to break
free of them
you might be right maybe there's a
better one that would help us think
about this
yeah when i first started on the project
of the clock i realized some of the best
representations i saw were actually
spiral because you have this notion
where you kind of
it's harder to know things really far in
the past and you know a lot more about
your present
actually one of the long now research
fellows has done an interesting computer
version of this that
i'd love to show you and actually it
probably could get posted in the chat
and we're going to be moving to some
questions from the chat uh we have uh
kevin kelly who's logged in from his
vacation
uh to uh to sort questions um
and one of his questions actually he's
he has he has several of them here
um but this one i really like which is
are there any
alternative theories about time that you
don't believe but can't dismiss
oh yeah i mean there's always plenty of
alternative theories right like any
good scientist knows that there's uh
lots of alternative theories out there
you know i made a lot of statements
in the talk which i think are true and i
would say that
if i if i just said the statements
flatly that not only do i think that
they are true but most people think that
they're true okay
so for example the statement that the
laws of physics
at the fundamental level have no
intrinsic time direction to them
and like i said that's true for newton's
equations for schrodinger's equation for
einstein's equations for maxwell's
equations what have you
but there are people out there who have
theories you know alternative theories
where time intrinsically has a direction
okay
i kind of think that's a waste of time
because they still need to understand
why the early universe has low entropy
and once you understand that time
effectively has a direction in our
macroscopic world so i i don't think
it's a
useful game to play to try to put
time directedness into the fundamental
equations of physics but i could be
wrong about that so i can't dismiss
it right and you mentioned how time and
linguistics are
are linked and i mean i assume that also
you know one of the things that
we do some language projects here at
long now and it's it's often said that
you know if you lose a language you lose
a world view
as well and have you found that there's
other cultures either
indigenous or modern that kind of
inherently understand
time the more the way physics physicists
do ah
so i don't know i what what i what i
completely agree with is the idea that
different cultures do understand time
very differently
um and some of them might become closer
to physics than
to sort of what we might call the modern
physics
attitude toward it but i'm just not
educated enough on
uh what those are you know and and if
there are any
you know i don't want to give either our
culture or any other cultures
too much credit because you know
when it comes to things like the large
scale history of the universe
well there's two options the universe is
eternal or it's finite in time and so
some
cultures had stories where it was finite
it had a beginning
other stories where it was infinite and
one of them's going to be right but
there's only two choices
neither one of them were on the basis of
data from telescopes right because even
right now
we do not know whether the universe
truly had a beginning or whether the big
bang was just a phase
so i think that there's lots of
different metaphors lots of different
stories lots of different cultural ways
of thinking about time
but even modern physics doesn't have the
right picture yet
so i'm not going to give credit to
anybody quite yet right
yeah we had a speaker early on who uh
dan everett is but studies the parraha
in central or south america and they
have a very very clearly a very
different conception of time i'm not
sure if it's more aligned with physics
or not
uh but much less about past and future
um
we have a great question here from uh
raphael
from the facebook feed says hi i'm a
teenager it's very common for people my
age to go through existential crisis
because of how massively large the
universe is
and how little significance our
individual lives have
is feeling my newt the right approach or
for visualizing ourselves
or how do you deal with this conception
of time in your own life
yeah you know raphael you're not wrong
to think that you're very very tiny
compared to the universe on the other
hand
you're very very big compared to an
electron uh and on the third hand who
cares who cares how big you are who
cares how long you're going to last
uh i do think it's important to
appreciate that we're finite we're
ephemeral as i said in the talk
we're not going to last forever and
therefore whatever it is that you find
meaningful and important and motivating
in your life
uh it can't be that you're gonna leave
an impression on the universe that lasts
literally forever because there are no
such impressions
and i actually find this liberating
rather than leading
to existential despair it takes the
burden away from me
to try to do something to the universe
that will actually
leave an imprint that lasts forever the
imprints that we leave on the universe
are finite but that doesn't make them
any less important for that
don't think about the universe think
about the people who you can affect
including yourself
uh the impact that you can have here and
in the near future
that's hard enough and it also matters
more than enough i would say nice
i like that actually uh rafael also had
raphael or rafael
as a second question um as as does kevin
kelly
kevin kelly is a little bit shorter
version of it but they're both about
dark matter and dark energy and so
kevin is asking if we know that there's
dark matter and there's
dark energy is there dark time no the
equivalent
no all right because let me
amplify you know time is not a substance
time is not something you can have a cup
of here's a cup of time right
dark matter is a substance it's a set of
particles you can move it around you can
say oh there's more dark matter over
here than over there
time is a label in modern physics right
it's a it's a way that we think about
where you are
in the universe in space-time what
exists is the universe time is a
language that we use to talk about
the universe so there's no sort of
equivalent different version of time
that would be darker or something like
that now
again having said that there will always
be people who disagree
you know that in the universe in which
we live there's three dimensions of
space
there's one dimension of time so it's
very very natural to say well why aren't
there two dimensions of time or three or
something like that and people have
tried to do that
none of these attempts has really led to
increasing our understanding of the
universe in fact they tend to make
things much much worse
so at least as far as we currently
understand it
the best way of thinking about the
universe is for time to be unique for
there to be one direction of time one
dimension of space time that we call
the temporal one again as a good
scientist you should always be open to
changing your mind in the future if good
information comes along
and that actually leads into a great
question from uh steven
from the facebook feed as well who's
asking about some of the recent quantum
experiments and how they can entangle
the future in the past
in some ways there's is that changing
some of notions of causality and
and entropy that maybe there's
connections beyond
between and around the present from the
future impasse
so here i will give you uh my personal
slightly grumpy view about these things
because
now we've moved on from time which is
easy to quantum mechanics which is hard
and what i mean by hard is that the
greatest theoretical physicists in the
world
don't agree on how quantum mechanics
works what it says etc
i have a point of view on this i just
wrote a book called something deeply
hidden
where i explain to you what my point of
view is but for the
purposes of this particular question
here is my point of view
no there's no thing as entanglement
at different moments of time not really
you
can choose to talk about the quantum
evolution of the universe
in such a way that you can kind of make
sense of such a thing but
you don't have to when you talk about
different
uh parts of the universe at one moment
of time
there's an objective fact of the matter
are they entangled with each other or
are they not
and everyone agrees on that and you can
talk about it and use it etc
in the conventional way of talking about
quantum mechanics that's all there is
the state of the universe exists at each
moment of time
just like in newtonian physics right in
newtonian physics as we talked about
if you have the positions like the solar
system positions and velocities of
everything
at one moment of time you can predict
the past present and future
same thing in quantum mechanics if you
know the quantum state at one moment of
time
you can predict what's going to happen
so i don't personally like to talk about
entanglement between different moments
of time you can but it seems to be just
an attempt to make things seem even more
confusing than they really are
right well yeah and you're taking away
so many good plot lines for
science fiction movies when you see this
uh yeah
my favorite uh description of the
quantum mechanics is from richard
feynman who said no one understands
quantum mechanics as one of the
inventors of the field
and uh kevin kelly is also asking uh
how has your own life changed since
since learning this is this
aside from this is something that you
teach but does this change the way you
actually think about
your the way your life works well um
in a in a fairly direct way it has
because you know i uh since i was 10
years old i wanted to be a theoretical
physicist
and i read about black holes and the big
bang and particles and i
i did it i eventually you know got to
the point where i was doing that
professionally
um when i was in college as an
undergraduate i also discovered
philosophy
and i fell in love with that also but it
seemed to be like a very different kind
of thing like the kind of philosophy
that i studied was actually political
and moral philosophy and there was some
philosophy of science in there
but that wasn't what my favorite kind of
philosophy was
it wasn't until you know i was a
professor already
and i thought a little bit about
cosmology a lot about cosmology actually
but i was thinking about the early
universe
and i got connected with philosophers
who weren't doing philosophy of science
in the sense they were studying how
science works
they were doing philosophy of science in
the sense they were studying how the
universe works
but in a more philosophical way and what
i realized was
they were making more sense when it came
to talking about the universe and time
than my physicist friends were and so i
became more philosophical myself
and that has continued on and i started
thinking about quantum mechanics and how
that works
how time works how space time itself
works how probability works
and these days what i do professionally
in my research career
is not even recognizable as cosmology
anymore
so in the down to earth sense that it
has changed my intellectual direction uh
very very much thinking thinking about
time was my
entry into thinking about the universe
in a more philosophical way
nice well and we have a question from uh
toss
rock from youtube it's actually asking
about you know how you
got involved in science and then going
on to doing things like working in the
movie industry and
advising on science fiction movies as we
were just discussing but i think
maybe another way to to think about this
is you know if if somebody
was starting a science career now in in
this space
um what would you tell them what would
you tell them to learn
what's the interesting space for a young
scientist to get into so that eventually
they get to be as cool as you advising
marvel look honestly there's the two
secrets to becoming a science advisor
for hollywood
are number one live in los angeles
that's where it's located uh number two
have a
at least medium-sized public profile be
out there on social media or writing
books or doing youtube
etc and they will find you there's no
systematic way you don't apply for a job
uh it's not a job you don't get paid
it's just kind of fun to talk to
directors and screenwriters about their
hollywood movies i got a sweatshirt once
an ironman sweatshirt that was kind of
fun
um but the other version of that
question is you know how do you get into
doing interesting science forgetting
about for the moment uh
movie consulting or anything like that
because there is a fundamental flaw in
the system
where if you're like me uh so i said i
got interested in physics when i was 10
years old so that's the middle
1970s and what are you going to do
you're going to be reading
about what is the most interesting
physics going on
at that point in time so i was reading
about quarks and black holes and the big
bang
and all that is great it's still great
now
but what you do for a living is not
going to be what's interesting when you
first
stumble across the field because there's
decades in between somehow right so
it's very hard to sort of plan ahead for
what will be
the most interesting stuff when you
become a grown-up scientist so
my advice is you know to think broadly
you know to be
open to all the different interesting
things going on um
be ready to say well you know what i
hadn't even thought of this whole
field that seems really cool let me at
least take it seriously you know
learn everything you can and put off to
the last minute choosing once and for
all what has to be your specialty
nice so we're going to be wrapping up
here shortly but i think one of the
things that you said that i thought was
really
interesting is that this idea that while
we have a lot more information about the
past
we obviously have much more influence on
the future and i think it's an
interesting thing that in our time
actually people feel as though they're
having less and less influence
on their future but i think it's a nice
message this idea that that's actually
the one thing we do have
influence over um and so that physics
backs that up
i think is is really great um and you
mentioned one of your recent books
um what are you what are you working on
now as slash next i know that
this topic was kind of a kind of dipping
into your past a bit
and which i thank you for but um what
what is your next current and next
uh work well the reason why i thought i
was very excited about doing this talk
is because even though i wrote a book
on the arrow of time over 10 years ago
now called from eternity to here
i'm actually again doing research on it
so
i'm doing research on this this question
of why
is it that you can have
effects and causes but the effects
always come after the causes
in other words why is the arrow of
causality aligned with the arrow of time
you know i
i talk about the arrow of time a lot of
my friends in physics or philosophy will
talk about multiple different
arrows of time the psychological arrow
the influence that we talked about the
thermodynamic arrow
so one ongoing project is relating them
all
to each other and i'm someone who
believes that the increase of entropy
is the reason why all these other arrows
exist but it's easy to say that out loud
it's hard to prove it with equations so
i'm i'm working on that as a as a
research project using
ideas from causal networks and bayesian
thinking
as well as thermodynamics and entropy
and philosophy of time
cool well thank you so much for joining
us this was so great to have you
and to actually get a kind of a very
fundamental sense of
time and us in it so thank you so much
my pleasure xander thanks very much for
having me on
thank you and i'd like to thank you our
along now audience um we actually have
several talks coming up in the future
that cross over uh fundamentals in
science such as color
and weather and how trees communicate so
please join us
for the weeks to come
you